ce groupe écologie démocratie solidarité
par des députés qui souhaitent porter
plus fort puissent ces valeurs dans le
redémarrage dans la feuille de route qui
arrive après l'épidémie de stop covin
l'écologie démocratie solidarité des
enjeux que nous ferons vivre dans le
dialogue avec les sciences avec les
citoyens alors quoi maintenant parce que
vous n'ignorez pas con on est face à un
problème environnemental majeur que ce
soit un réchauffement climatique
que ce soit les questions de
biodiversité par ailleurs
n'y aurait pas non plus que la crise va
impacter sur le quotidien de beaucoup de
françaises et de français
particulièrement sur les questions de
solidarité on a repensé notre modèle
fait un certain nombre de propositions à
travers ce groupe serré groupes
politiques avec une attention forte
c'est de faire des propositions pour la
france